hey everybody it's pete holmes from the
pete home show and uh you know 2014 good
lord is that right 2014 is right around
the corner which means i thought it
would be fun to look back on this year
and uh pick out my top five sketches of
2013.
the unlucky here
why do they call it overalls they don't
cover all of you
they don't even cover your arms they
should be called over mosts
number five is new material seinfeld
another dream come true for me new
material is something i've done with my
friend joe derosa and
just walking around
new york city spotting things and doing
bad seinfeld material it's just the sort
of joke you go what are we going to do
with this you can't do it in your stand
up you can't do it on someone else's
show you need your own show
and suddenly we have our own show and we
got to bring new material seinfeld to
life seeing a puppet
you know picking up a phone and going we
need a puppet to play seinfeld and then
to have a puppet delivered later that
day that's what makes this job so
wonderful it's like working in a weird
magical chocolate factory where we just
make funny things and sometimes actually
chocolate we're having a bake sale for
season two
heaven boom here i am cause i did it and
i knew it
clouds check
gates
shack saint peter shack me
number four is heaven i knew it uh this
this one just killed me most of the
footage of that day is me laughing and
ruining takes because matt mccarthy
hands down one of the funniest people
i've ever known and ever gotten to work
with and a good friend of mine just
completely stole the scene watch i could
watch this over and over and over and uh
sending that to hell was also kind of
fun
you leave the air conditioning running
full blast
in your cavernous lobby all day
and all night
and you want me to be green
how about this
wash my damn towels number three is uh
wash my damn towels uh you know the
setup to this joke is completely true i
do travel a lot i see that sign a lot
and i've been alone in hotels across
this great country screaming wash my
damn towels so needless to say it's an
incredible dream come true to see that
kind of uh malfunction
glorified on a tv show that has my name
which newsy did you base clark kent off
of
was it crutchy i'm not crunchy getting a
strong feeling that it was crunchy i'm
not crunchy number two is batman versus
superman i i love doing the batman
videos with uh my friend orrin brimmer
we've been doing them with college humor
for a very long time but more
importantly i've always hated superman
what a boring milktoast piece of [__]
hero he is go back to the 30s
[__]
what is a motorcycle
made of
tubes
i'm sorry you say tubes glass and tubes
clocking in at number one is x-men
wolverine just a huge fun time with my
friend george basil one of the funniest
people around it was so fun to uh kind
of [__] on a superhero i actually do
like so much so that it actually caught
the attention of the real wolverine
not that there's no real wolverine but
it caught the attention of hugh jackman
a song and dance man who also plays an
action hero
so that's it everybody those are my top
five moments of 2013 can't wait to see
what 2014 brings and so you don't miss
out when we do that click subscribe do
it click on subscribe and then whenever
we post something new you know how
subscriptions work
you'll be in the loop you don't want to
be left out like the cool kids in the
parking lot smoking